you
hello welcome to another episode on
matrix math here in code tanking
tutorials my name is Matt today we were
going to talk about vectors and we're
also gonna cover magnitude what a unit
vector is and how to normalize them
these are all very relevant parts of a a
matrix a special matrix so a vector is a
special matrix and it is one in which it
is of size n by one or 1 by n so if it's
n by one it's a column vector where it
has n rows and one column so it might
look something like this and it can go
as far down or however big you want it
to be to the size of n and likewise if
it's a row vector
it goes like so and so on and of course
these elements can be anything they're
not necessarily going to be a simple
number that's just standard with
matrixes
so let's talk a little bit about what
all we can do with them one of the main
things you'll see is magnitude and to
calculate a Mack magnitude on a vector
you basically square each element and
then add them all together and then take
the square root of that result so it'll
look something like this say we have a Y
and its standard to represent vectors as
a bold lowercase letter
whereas matrices are often an uppercase
bold letter
so we'll say y equals I don't let's just
do some sort of simple result we'll do a
1 a 7 of 0 negative 2 we'll just keep it
that small and magnitude is often shown
by these two bars on either side so if
you have some sort of question for
example words what is the magnitude of Y
you don't say well the magnitude of Y is
1 squared plus 7 squared plus 0 squared
put these in parentheses so that's how
it's often represented plus negative 2
squared and then the square root of all
that so that is going to equal 2 plus
what's 7 times 7 49 0 squared of course
is 0 plus 0 and then negative 2 squared
turns into 4 it's negative 2 times
negative 2 and of course square root of
all that and that's going to equal let's
see 51 plus another 4 so square root of
55 is the result so the magnitude of
this Y vector is 55 there's there's the
answer now the magnitude is important
because you can use it to fun to
normalize a vector so we want to
normalize the same vector let me do a
quick copy here I'm just going to copy
this then we're going to go to a new
layer paste it in merge it down anchor
down whatever it takes okay there we go
and I'll put in here normalize
and I guess why we're at it I'll go
ahead and define unit vector
well a vector is called a unit vector if
its magnitude is equal to one so if you
calculate them calculate off the
magnitude and it's just the number one
then you have a unit vector
okay let's continue on so if you want to
find the normalized y
and fine fine normalized do some other
own tool here I'll put find analyze this
first you want to remember them the
magnitude or get the magnitude so we've
already figured out that the magnitude
of Y is square root of 55 so what we do
is we take each individual element and
we divide it by the magnitude so it's
going to look like this
now I'll put a big line across here to
show that we're working a new problem so
it's give me 1 over square root of 55
plus oh not a plus it's just a vector so
that's the first element this is the
second element there's the next element
which of course is just going to stay at
zero put zero divided by anything well
it's going to stay zero and here's the
four is it fourth one
and there you go so that is going to be
the normalized
you
vector and I think that's going to be it
thank you for watching this video and I
hope to see you next one hope this
helped understand vectors and how to
normalize them how that all works and
let's see here we're just going to read
a quick definition a vector is called a
unit vector if its magnitude is equal to
one a nonzero vector is said to be
normalized if it is divided by its
magnitude as a normalized vector is also
a unit vector so this should now be a
unit vector
alright thanks again I'll see you in the
next episode keep on learning guys and
don't forget to give this like to help
with the YouTube algorithm and help my
channel a little bit help this video get
seen peace out